hello and welcome to the 2023 spring
meetings of the World Bank group and IMF
my name is Paul Blake I'll be guiding
you through the next hour as we discuss
avoiding debt crises and generating
growth now remember you can share your
thoughts on these topics at any time
using the hashtag reshapingdevelopment I
can use the QR code to post your
questions online and if you're joining
us online you can head over to
live.worldbank.org and join the chat
there now I'm pleased to introduce you
to our president here at the World Bank
group David Malpass his Excellency Nigel
Clark Jamaica's Finance Minister and
minister of Public Service Tina
vandersteel lead emerging debt portfolio
manager at GMO a us-based global
investment firm the University of
Chicago's Raghu Rajan
and his Excellency Ahmed Shide Minister
of Finance from Ethiopia thank you all
for being here David over to you thank
you Paul uh welcome to the 2023 spring
meetings of the World Bank group uh and
the IMF under the theme reshaping
development for a new era we'll be
discussing how to unlock growth and
poverty reduction around the world we
start the week off with debt
sustainability that's a topic that is
key for growth and development around 40
low-income countries and a dozen
middle-income countries are at high risk
of debt distress or in debt distress in
addition slowing Global growth and
higher interest rates globally are
putting additional pressure on
developing countries the World Bank has
advocated strongly for solutions to the
mounting debt challenge facing
developing countries and we've been
providing fresh grants and highly
concessional resources to countries in
debt distress often when no one else is
providing in financing along with the
IMF and India as the G20 President we
are co-chairing the global sovereign
debt Roundtable it brings together a
wide range of stakeholders and aims to
bring consensus and recommend measures
to accelerate debt relief the in-person
meeting of the round table is tomorrow
progress on debt has been stalled and
it's urgent that we move forward
promptly countries need to achieve
transparent and sustainable debt burdens
in order to restart investment which has
slowed to a standstill today we're
bringing together this illustrious panel
to discuss the latest difficulties in
sovereign debt markets and possible
solutions I'll turn to Professor Ragu
Raghu Rajan with my first question and
that's a general question uh Professor
will you describe the the debt context
for the world and what the global
context is of the challenge that we're
facing now thanks sure uh absolutely uh
let me uh very quickly go through the
obvious right these are difficult times
uh interest rates around the world have
been rising uh hopefully the FED doesn't
have too much more to go but clearly it
seems as if the ultimate Way inflation
will be brought down is by a slowing of
the economy in the United States either
because of higher rates themselves or
because of financial Vector credit
contraction or some combination of the
two so we are going to get slowing
growth in this country
probably also in Europe where core
inflation is still very strong and uh
perhaps some slowing is necessary to
bring those economies back on track on
the inflationary track and of course
with higher interest rates
we've got higher real interest rates uh
and uh on the on the cards in in times
to come for now
um it's it's a little bit of a wash
depending on what what nominal interest
rates are but but over time we will have
a period of higher real interest rates
while we're trying to slow down the
economy and of course hiring real
interest rates feed into the rest of the
world's debt because they determine the
rollover rates for the debt there and
become a higher burden when you include
through that credit spreads and so on
the risk of pattern in global capital is
also concerned for many emerging markets
in developing countries in the sense
that it becomes significantly harder to
roll over debt so all this is
um you know stuff that you know stuff
that you uh are cognizant of what is
more worrisome is the enormous spending
needs that many emerging markets in
developing countries now have
as as you know they had a terrible
pandemic the lower middle class in many
countries didn't have uh regular jobs uh
certainly when when they were locked
Downs uh many small and medium
Enterprises certainly in my country
India suffered tremendously during the
pandemic so these uh months have been
periods of slow recovery for large
segments of the population segments that
didn't have regular employment uh and
and small and medium firms that didn't
have regular business and in this time
what we're seeing is an interrupted
recovery as we have higher interest
rates uh difficulty in borrowing uh
interrupting the process of recovery so
the bad pandemic is one source of
concern and of course the bad pandemic
leads to bad politics one of the uh
articles in the financial times today
was how insurance companies are paying
out more for unrest
for losses due to unrest and that's a
feature that is emerging in many
countries because the lower middle class
is extremely upset with what they've
been through over the last few years
that doesn't make for good politics so
bad pandemic bad politics and therefore
bad often macro uh uh policies in a
number of countries that uh sort of if
already capital is a little worried that
pushes Capital even further away
we've also got you know interrupted
development the pandemic sort of slowed
down development in a number of
countries enormous development needs as
we well know across the world but add to
that the concerns associated with
climate change the fact that you know
farmers in Pakistan are still dealing
with the consequences of the flood last
year that these are increasing
catastrophes around the developing world
that need to be dealt with often they
need quick spending not so much on
mitigation but on adaptation and
resilience which are important uh for
for their continued uh well-being so all
these imply enormous spending needs and
last point and I'll stop there
where's the available Capital with
industrial countries basically have
having big spending needs of their own
both in terms of higher government
spending through the pandemic which will
wind down slowly but also the enormous
new spending that a number of countries
are contemplating on climate action so
what is left is significantly smaller
for the rest of the world there's a
crowding out happening not so much of
private Capital but about of capital to
the rest of the world so this is the
environment uh hopefully uh I've touched
on the big themes in which we want to
talk about the specifics of what's
Happening yeah that thanks is a huge
problem of the absorption of uh really
The Whole World's Capital by the
advanced economies at a time when the
developing countries need some kind of
new investment in order to get over
their spending needs and uh address the
climate costs that are that are large
um so and you you didn't so much mention
it but we will be discussing it all week
is the debt restructuring that's so
important because the countries are
still uh paying so much for debts that
were incurred over the last decade uh
that it's uh it creates challenges for
their spending side as well so let's
turn to minister Sheed
um Ahmed
Ethiopia requested uh G20 common
framework treatment uh a little over two
years ago it's still waiting to pick up
steam uh tell us a little about the debt
restructuring process why is that
important how does it affect your your
growth and your sustainability as a as a
country thanks thank you David first of
all I would like to express my
appreciation for the G20 initiative this
is a timely initiative and
it is very important particularly given
the challenge we are undergoing the
developing countries like Ethiopia but
the process as you have said took more
than two years since the initiative has
been has been announced we have applied
it and the process was very very slow
and that is one of the challenges
macroeconomic imbalance has widened
recently due to internal and external
pressures and the shocks that have
challenged us the drought the war in
Ukraine all have significant impact in
terms of literating external positions
and declining of international reserve
and that's why death treatment and also
additional reform measures is very
fundamental to to close the gap in terms
of macro imbalance and to move to
sustainable trajectory
I would like to note that also
we for the last four years
since the new government has been in
place the last five years we never had
any borrowing when it comes to
non-concessional borrowing we have a
very stringent requirement on
non-concessional borrowing limit and we
have adhered to that one to make sure
that we are in we have a physical
discipline
we are currently working with IMF and
the World Bank in restoring a
macroeconomic imbalance through our own
homegrown program reform program which
is very much important to address the
imbalance we are having
Ethiopia situation in terms of their
situation is different from Chad Ghana
and Zambia because Utopia does not have
any external payment area so far our
debt parameters are very clear and more
straightforward we do not have any
challenges that other countries do with
questions about presidency and domestic
debt holding as well
Ethiopia's biggest challenge is most of
the repayment of the loan has to happen
within the coming few years
the coming what the coming few years we
need to repay a lot of debts yeah
significant chunk of the debts is going
to be repaid within the coming few years
so that is going to put us in a very
significant pressure given the the
export level which has to yet to grow
therefore that service to export ratio
is also deteriorating
so the external imbalance which is
happening due to global food shock and
other commodity price increase has
exacerbated our external positions so
Ethiopia's challenge is not only
internal it's also external challenge
with which has exacerbated or for the
conflict and the drought and all has
contributed also to the shocks we are
enduring that's why
it could have been because of
our reform measures that we built some
level of resilience in our system even
the situation could have been worse
without the reform
the treatment we need in terms of that
treatment is not complex what we need is
for the decision to come through quickly
we had a fruitful discussion with IMF
team recently for a potential program we
are continuing to discuss with both IMF
on the bank for a potential program
and I expect I expect the DSA should be
shared with a creditor committee but we
need to move very quickly the time is of
urgency and I think slowness in the
common framework in the giving of DSA
data to co-creator committee more
coordination between the bank and IMF
and creditor committee as part of G20
common framework is very very vital
thank you David
yeah thanks and so you mentioned the DSA
so the debt sustainability analysis is a
product jointly done by the World Bank
and the IMF and gives some uh concept of
what the financing needs are and each
country is quite different Ethiopia has
more of a liquidity uh uh
problems
short-term liquidity challenge
short-term liquidity challenge that
would come out and so one of the things
we're pushing strongly for in the debt
Roundtable tomorrow is early uh sharing
of the DSA with a more inclusive group
it's been kept private within the uh uh
with the in the IMF and World Bank for
all these years uh when it's a vital
document for uh for all the creditors to
think about the country itself can
benefit from looking at the debt
sustainability analysis and the private
sector so I'll come to Tina uh
vandersteel uh your uh you do you look
at dsa's debt sustainability analyzes
put out by the IMF and the World Bank
how do they affect your thinking on
countries and the bigger picture
question what how do you think what
would be good for uh catalyzing new
investment into poor countries into
developing countries we we think a
faster debt restructuring process would
actually be helpful but what are your
thoughts on the timing of a debt
restructuring process whether it's a
good idea and then what documents would
be helpful to get it done
absolutely thank you for having me and
uh to be clear about representing the
private sector here
um I work for an asset management firm
so we represent savers of of different
varieties including Pension funds and
endowments Sovereign wealth funds that
type of thing so generally when people
think about the private sector they're
thinking about well how does the private
sector think about lending to an
emerging country in the first place
and if you start at the highest level
the asset allocation level they see
emerging debt as an asset class like any
other lending asset class corporate
credit either investment grade or in
this case sub-investment grade and what
you're going to look for is a return
that is an in excess of expected credit
losses right so sovereigns have
defaulted over time we have a lot of
history of sovereign defaults and so you
can project some of those and a DSA is a
terrific way to socialize the IMF and
World bank's thinking about the
sustainability of the debt because if
you think about it from a lender's
perspective and you know that there's
some chance that the country will run
into trouble it's good to know whether
or not the IMF or World Bank thinks that
what are the assumptions that they're
making because obviously debt
sustainability is a fluid concept
conditional on the macroeconomic
environment debts that were sustainable
before the pandemic may not be after the
pandemic unforeseen things can happen so
for sure as an anchor it would be
critical and from the point of view of
transparency which is of course a key
theme in the common framework investors
would love at all stages more
transparency
more transparency lowers ex-ante debt uh
interest expectations that we would have
because we have a full picture of what's
going on
well I ask a specific on that have you
do you see the financing assurances that
are given to the IMF and the World Bank
as a IMF program is put together
because that becomes a critical thing of
what do the what do the various
creditors commit the official creditors
commit to doing over a period of time
well so if I think about the last 15
years or so how that has happened has
evolved right so let's say the the
classic of debtors that we're talking
about right now are the ones that are
very low income they have a reasonable
chance of debt distress and how for
example the imf's thinking on that
evolved through Greece
uh was a pretty big change right it was
we will not lend into uh this kind of
situation except in a systemic idea and
so the policy changed through 2012 and
then changed again through 2016 to say
we will uh we won't lend but we will
allow others to lend other official
creditors and so for example China and
Saudi Arabia became big lenders in those
situations and as investors and private
sector investors we have a very good
history of understanding the seniority
and the expectations of IMF World Bank
lending but we don't have a good history
and understanding of what either soe
lending by the Chinese or swap lines
extended how that will be treated and
whether we will be subordinate to that
and all of those things play into the
price we would expect for the debt X
anti Easter
that raises a whole another round of
questions that's that's really good and
so for people's background I guess or
the way I I think in really simplistic
terms uh in a bankruptcy process there's
debtor in possession so after the
bankruptcy is declared then new new
lenders can come in and they have
seniority over the old lenders because
they're doing something useful and it's
agreed on by the group that they can
come in and and make extra loans but uh
there's not that kind of uh organized
process with regard to Sovereign
Sovereign restructuring processes so you
don't know at the various stages of a
restructuring whose credits are going to
be treated as senior to the ones you've
lent to well that's interesting and I
hope at the round table this week we can
discuss things like that we do have on
the table the question of how are
arrears going to be treated uh during
the restructure during process so that
can at least give a little bit of a hook
into that well let me turn to Nigel of a
very successful Finance Minister and
Senior government minister in Jamaica
you you undertook reforms and I I don't
know whether how how early you started
within this process but Jamaica is
notable in having tackled the debt
problem earlier we've encouraged and
really encouraged countries to go as
early as they as soon as they see a
problem begin talking with people about
how to get out of the problem because
otherwise they fall into a debt trap it
gets it it's not as if it's going to get
better and Jamaica broke out of that
starting in in
2010 through 13. so what are your and
that had to do with domestic debt which
is an issue facing a lot of developing
countries the the government may borrow
from Banks uh domestic Banks and and
that itself creates its own uh set of
problems how did Jamaica break out of
that and what lessons do you have for
the for the group on debt restructurings
right so Jamaica had an experience of
about 50 years in a debt trap right for
a very long time we had high elevated
levels of debt for a variety of reasons
which we won't get into here we learned
through that experience that ultimately
high debt uh introduces fiscal rigidity
and shocks your ability to respond to
crises and as a result crises last
longer they become more intense they
become deeper and you don't have
resources to invest in uh social
expenditure and growth inducing capital
expenditure
2010 we made a stability to uh to
restructure domestic debt and to engage
in a suite of reforms it got interrupted
and we went again in 2013 and again did
a domestic damage to recapitalize Banks
or what does that mean no no we there
was there we didn't have a banking
sector in 2010 we had a banking sector
issue in the 90s and the cost of uh
intervening was 40 of GDP it was
socialized borne by the government and
in this lot let's say this last 25 years
or 30 years of our debt experience uh is
inextricably linked with the banking
sector fail in the 1990s for your
Audience by virtue by comparison the
financial sector crisis here in the
United States in 2008 to 2010 was about
nine percent of GDP so 40 percent 40 of
GDP and it wasn't a market solution the
government took it on and we just never
worked that debt off and it brought us
into crisis uh in uh in so we look at
the period 2010 to 2023 as sort of one
period but we look more closely at 2013
to 2023 because in 2013 Jamaica was on
its knees and I if I were to summarize I
would say uh
in the context of a social consensus
about the need for reform government
can't do it alone uh but broad societal
consensus unions business Academia
government opposition
Jamaica resolved to move in a different
direction and a combination of laws
institutions and principled
decision-making uh on the pin by
higher levels of fiscal transparency
just briefly on each of those laws
passed a series of laws on Revenue
Administration laws that reform public
uh the public pension system was
reformed in 2017 which led to
contributary pension uh uh you know
Arrangements laws to do
with moving from direct to indirect
Taxation and so forth institutions we
would have brought into being uh
institutions like independent fiscal
commission which is in the the pipeline
deepmin fiscal transparency and giving
it an Institutional structure apparatus
we made our Central Bank Independent we
had Jamaica is characterized by huge
levels of fiscal dominance where the
central bank was didn't have any choice
but to pursue monetary policy that
allowed the government to keep borrowing
we dismantled that and that sent huge
signals to the private sector and as far
as laws are concerned we instituted
fiscal rules that the government over
the past 10 years has followed has have
governments have followed that targeted
a fiscal balance each year that's
consistent with a medium-term debt
objective but you can't just put an
institution in place or enact some laws
and then say hey my work is done what
you need is active principal decision
making because they the events their boy
events as the former prime minister of
England said that come your way can't be
predicted and you have to apply
principal decision making to maneuver
through those events take what happened
over the last three years Jamaica got
its debt down from 147 percent of GDP
all the way down to 94 of GDP uh over a
seven year period and then kovit comes a
contraction by 10 debt goes back up to
110. alarm Bells go off because before
we went to 147 the train stopped before
that was 115. so at 110 are we going to
go back
no we escaped from our physical rules
but our policy approach was targeted and
temporary unlike what we saw in many
parts of the world where uh it wasn't
targeted everybody particip everybody
got so to speak and it wasn't temporary
so targeted and temporary allowed us to
uh maneuver through the covet crisis and
maneuver through the inflation crisis
that followed uh with very uh what
policies that were carefully calibrated
and as a result of principal decision
making supported by fiscal transparency
social consensus institutions and laws
Jamaica has a distinction as at the end
of 2022 of being with the exception of
Guyana that discovered oil the only
country in the Western Hemisphere that
can say the following three things one
economic output in real terms is higher
in 2022 than it was prior to the
pandemic two unemployment is low in 2022
than it was prior to the pandemic and a
few people can say that but no one can
say those two plus the third our debt as
at 2022 was lower prior to the pandemic
or debt to GDP ratio lower than prior to
the pandemic and it's a combination of
those that I just described very
succinctly that would have allowed us to
achieve such an outcome I'm glad you
mentioned subsidies we've seen uh
worldwide the uh the high cost of
subsidies that are not targeted so when
they and also ones that persisted much
longer than they've been intended and
that's a core of the fiscal challenges
uh uh facing many countries did
investors come back in So after the 2013
crisis
what did investors take notice well it
took a long time for people to believe
uh-huh um you know important signals had
to be sent uh prior to 2013 uh Jamaica
missed its fiscal Target every year with
in the previous 10 years every year with
exception of probably one year since
2013 we have hit our fiscal targets
every single year
confidence eventually goes up because
the signals that are being sent uh and
we know we saw earlier this year in
other parts of the world how important
signals are right so uh the the and
let's talk about this recent period of
of covid the signals that the government
sent about being targeted and about
being temporary escaping from the fiscal
rules but going right back
all right after the storm had passed
they're not waiting too long when the
covert crack when the Ukraine uh sorry
the inflation crisis came resisting the
temptation to implement policies that
are characterized by huge amounts of
fiscal leakage right because your help
your your instead of targeting to the
the bottom half of the country where the
need is greatest everybody has needs but
it's about prioritizing where the needs
are greatest those signals uh you know
send were sent to investors that this
country is serious we are not only put
in institutions and laws but we're we're
being principled in our decision making
and that allowed for the economic
unemployment results I just described
thanks much Tina's short answer do you
invest in Jamaica we certainly do can
and in Ethiopia you could we are also
investing interesting uh we'll come back
to that Ragu uh comment on anything
you've heard and uh and specifically or
if you want on the debt restructuring
process says anything that you think
should be done to make it go faster well
um let let me just start with the data
and possession idea that's that's
floating uh here I'm clearly countries
that are in desperate need uh and don't
have a program in place would benefit
from something which allows them access
to finance in the short run prevent a
lot of damage to the people prevent the
political sort of upheaval that usually
emerges at such times
there are two issues there however right
one is you don't want the data and
possession financing to be invoked to
get financing which prolongs the old
problem that they got into trouble
because they over invested in
Grand projects which led nowhere uh they
spent a lot on that you don't want those
to be completed off the backs of of
people who are suffering what you want
is uh that to be stopped while uh money
is flowing through in the right
direction so it does mean a certain kind
of targeting of the resources that are
raised through data and possession
financing and how do you get that that's
that's that's that's very important
second I do think that the time for data
and position financing is when you lose
access and the sooner it is to that
point of loss lost taxes the better it
is how do you determine whether the
country has lost access that's the
that's the other issue we need to think
about but I think it's a great idea it
does raise the overall question of
whether priority structures
over and above the preferred status of
the ifis is something we need to be
thinking about it does open a whole new
set of issues do countries sort of
dilute previous lenders by giving new
lenders higher priority and does this
become then a a a process which is not
credible aren't we already do it and so
that's the swap line point that was made
so if an external creditor comes in with
a central bank swap line doesn't it take
precedence over even IMF and World Bank
in terms of the the credits the capital
stack absolutely I think what you're
asking for is we need to bring order to
this what is the structure of priority
under what circumstances does a
particular line get priority over the
others and how does this affect the
overall resource envelope and that's
something that needs to be discussed of
course at the back of it is also what's
the restructuring process how does that
take into account all these different
priorities and and that as you know is
is a big throat issue this is one of the
themes for the round table tomorrow is
the predictability of the process has
value to quite a few of the participants
Tina raised it the private sector would
would is happy to consider and analyze
situations if there's some
predictability in what will happen and
you're describing it as we don't know
yet how that will all work out right and
and trying to figure that is is is
important uh two other small points I
mean one is the uh you know we talked
about targeting uh and and temporary and
targeted and what is disappointing is
how we've lost track of that in
industrial countries the temporary and
targeting aspect of it and part of I
think the reason why that is happening
is because the politics in industrial
countries have become so much more
fractured the consensus uh that here's
how we approach this particular problem
has sort of broken down because they're
different constituencies who benefit and
instead of saying we targeted to this
constituency and not that now the answer
is we targeted to everybody uh and and
of course that implies much greater
spending I mean think for example about
how we're approaching climate action
because it's so hard to get carbon taxes
in this country it's all about subsidies
but clearly that implies an enormous
amount of spending from the government
to incentivize something which could be
done more cheaply through taxes on the
private sector and that's a place where
resources probably are being used in
less than efficient ways last point we
absolutely need to think about what
happens post the restructuring right as
you said
lots of developing countries in deep
stress
but we also know that there were a lot
of countries in deep stress 20 years ago
and we did the uh debt forgiveness uh
which which created space some countries
use that space very well others did not
and the question is
at a time where political buy-in for
this kind of restructuring is difficult
from the government side of course the
private sector side doesn't want this to
continue happening otherwise it gets uh
it loses interest in financing how do we
get countries to commit to a process by
which
post the restructuring there is sensible
spending going forward what are the
institutional structures that need to be
built
with the country itself
keeping control over the process by
which debt Rises especially given the
frequency of catastrophes will probably
increase spending will be needed but you
need to skill keep buffers for uh future
events this is a really important point
of okay if we could resolve the debt the
past debt crisis how could we create an
environment into the future where more
borrowing could be done on a safer or on
a more sustainable basis we're you know
we are strongly advocating transparency
which was missing you referred to the
previous debt the hipic initiative the
highly indebted poor countries
initiative which then was supposed to
create an environment that it wouldn't
happen again in and yet it didn't work
and so we we want to strongly encourage
more transparency in the new lending
that comes on stream and then also
within Ida we have the sdfp the
sustainable development developing
Finance policy which encourages
countries to have a a sustainable
relationship in their new debt and uh uh
Ahmed already mentioned Ethiopia has not
been done been doing
non-concessional borrowing which was at
the core of the post-typic environment
that the idea was you were not supposed
to borrow on a non-concessional basis
after getting debt relief and that would
make you more sustainable into the
future so Ethiopia is trying that now
but he was very careful to say that
that's part of the new government of
Ethiopia is trying not to do uh
concessional borrowing so let me turn to
you Ahmed you've heard that so there
have been quite a few points made one is
the need for targeted uh subsidies uh
can you do that and then I'll also
mention the the the fundamental
separation that was done in Jamaica of
monetary from fiscal policy in order to
create a a sustainable hole can Ethiopia
do that you have a heavily mixed
monetary and fiscal policy where the
monetary policy subsidizes fiscal uh and
uh uh and has a dual exchange rate so
but the the question really is what
kinds of reforms do you envision as new
international resources come to bear in
Ethiopia thank you very much first our
approach is that since the new
government has been in place the last
four years we have been doing our own
homegrown economic reform program
its fundamental objective was to to
sustain growth
within within the macroeconomic balance
framework and we have analyzed the
problem of inflation the Forex challenge
Rising that risk as a binding constraint
for the economy at large and for
attracting private sector investment and
we have been rebalancing the role of the
state in terms of in the economy we have
been creating more space for private
sector LED growth which is very
important on fuel on subsidies for
example we have
we have we are downsizing the westfull
fuel subsidies which we have been giving
generally to the to the whole public now
we are moving toward a targeted fuel
subsidy
for the first few years of the reform
for example in terms of monetary
Financial fiscal policy we have
fundamentally constrained the National
Bank borrowing to the government and it
has been significantly reduced but due
to multiple challenges of domestic
conflict
drought
and desert Locust and also International
Food shock and also Community price
increase we have to somehow
Finance this growing needs even now the
the need for the Reconstruction and
Recovery requires a significant amount
of financing which has to be both
domestic and international that's why
our partnership with all bank and IMF is
very important and critical in this time
in our history where we are moving
toward bold reform but at the time where
this multiple challenges requires us to
spend more on basic development and
social spending as well so I think the
the G20 common framework are very
commendable but the process took much
longer
and we have been penalized as a result
of applying for it we pay the cost for
example our Euro Bond
the this price speed has increased
and we have been downside down
downgraded by by by rating agencies this
has been huge huge cost to the economy
and therefore yet the benefit of the G20
government framework has yet to come and
I think the issue is
flexibility for the countries are very
important one size fits all shouldn't
have to be applied to utopia's case our
data are very transparent
we are we have few major creditors it's
very clear so there's a calculation will
should not take even much more time it's
very easy process our situation is
different from other countries
situations so each countries a specific
context has to be dealt with
specifically therefore real-time
coordination between IMF World Bank and
G20 common Frameworks Secretariat and
the Creditor committee are very very
important in terms of sharing the DSA
data and also treating countries
differently according to their problems
is very important there has to be also
time-bound Clarity over when this
process is going to deliver therefore I
think this is very very important
Ethiopia is committed to to to address
the macro imbalance particularly the
exchange rate reform is very important
the current exchanger team is not
sustainable as well as it is
distortionary to the economy we need to
boldly address it but we will continue
with our discussion with IMF team with
World Bank in terms of how boldly to
move forward but Utopia also needs
significant support
both on fiscal front on financial sector
modernization so that we can lay the
foundation for sustainable private
sector lead growth thank you yeah thank
you thank you and we heard the context
from Nigel of 25 years falling into the
a deep debt trap and then it took some
years of confidence building and we're
trying to accelerate as much as possible
in Ethiopia that confidence uh uh
building period uh and and also your
point is of interest to everyone of as
the interest rates go up uh one of the
phenomena in the world is several con
currencies have been weakening and that
digs the digs the debt trap uh deeper as
the currencies weaken so breaking out of
that is a critical part of that uh steps
forward so to Tina I'll ask
um uh uh
Ahmed was mentioning the Bold reforms
and the eurobond downgrading so tell us
anything any of your thoughts what do
you want to invest in do you look at
rating agencies when they downgrade he's
he's raised this problem that if you
declare for the common framework the
downgrade is rather quick coming out of
it because there's not certainty in the
process and it may take years and years
so the downgrade comes the investors go
away what any Reflections on that for us
what should we do I mean that's a that's
an important uh point actually to me
it's fascinating the the contrast
between Jamaica and Ethiopia in a number
of different respects
mostly the debt path dependency so
Nigel's described this hump and coming
back down so by the time you were
borrowing the last Euro bonds the 28s
and the 45s back in 2015 your single B
rated and you're paying about 500 basis
points of sovereign spread
Ethiopia
had its debts wiped out under hipic
early in the 2000s 10 years later comes
to Market at a single B rating roughly
a sovereign spread of 435
right
Jamaica now at 300 right a lot of fiscal
discipline you know you're starting with
very high debt coming down you're
starting with very low debt coming up
right and Jamaica takes the opportunity
to pre-finance upcoming liabilities so
the 25s I think are mostly paid off at
this point so this debt cliff
that you know probably in 2018 2019
nobody was too worried about but you
throw in a couple of giant shocks and
then suddenly a rollover of one big
looming maturity December of next year
seems like a big deal nobody could have
forecast that it would have gone this
way
um from the point of view of an investor
we're only kind of interested in the
credit rating and when I say that that's
because a credit rating is designed to
tell investors the probability of their
being an event
but it doesn't tell you the severity of
the event right so in your case because
you face a rollover challenge you don't
have very high debt levels then any
preemptive type restructuring that other
countries have done in fact Jamaica did
itself back in 2013 or so a preemptive
restructuring can end up with relatively
High npvs such that investors are fine
to keep going
so that's how we would see it as
investors
the process being slowed as part of j20
common framework for with the Creator
countries is also affecting for example
how to restructure the upcoming the big
payment we have to face in 2024 in terms
of one billion dollar euro Bond so time
is and the urgency of essence in terms
of G20 common framework
so I would agree
and do you think a Euro boundary
scheduling is possible just to put you
on there it happens it happens all the
time okay if I think about Uruguay
there's been some very useful preemptive
restructurings let's spend a minute if
we can on uh tools uh so one was
mentioned you pre-j Jamaica has
pre-funded its 2025 I heard I heard Tina
say and then I I have a note here that
Petro Caribe that you're one of the
first to buy it back at a discount and
then you also I know working with the
with the World Bank you've done a
catastrophe Bond and so any reflection
do you have any other uh tools that
you're you're contemplating the world
wants to be Innovative in terms of its
Financial interaction you've done that
are there more things in line that could
be done a good question so Jamaica is
very proud of being an innovator those
are two very good examples the Patrick
buyback we were one of the the first
country if not the first country to
actually engage in such a transaction
and we became last year the first
country the first small independent
country in the world to independently
sponsor a catastrophe bond with World
Bank assistance uh we are
used to Jamaica is comfortable with
taking a leadership position uh has a
self-confidence to uh to go forward even
where no other country in our region is
happening to do the same thing and we we
we we do believe that there are other
areas in which we could continue to
innovate one of the things that we're
trying to work on is to get other
countries in our region interested in a
catastrophe Bond so instead of Jamaica
doing it on its own and we did this for
the demonstration effect we have been
having dialogue you know with you with
the world bank's assistance with other
countries in the region if we could in
this era where climate changes has
gathered such attention and focus if we
were to go to the market with a single
catastrophe bond that covered the region
the pricing would be better the coverage
would be higher
um and that would be uh an innovation in
that particular space
yeah and and so we we are we
um as people know if you can spread the
risk then it uh improves the pricing and
so diversifying risk is a key part of
this we've pushed strongly for uh
infrastructure as an asset class that
would be Diversified I see Paul coming
on but Raghu last word and then we'll go
to Paul just from this uh last point
about Innovative financing
I I wonder if uh entities like the World
Bank I mean the IMF goes out to try and
raise money when there's a catastrophe
worldwide catastrophe and that's when
it's the hardest to raise money right uh
from its uh its uh shareholders and so
on
could you create a buffer fund where you
take commitments in Good Times
everybody's willing to lend
just like private Equity raises a fund
you raise a fund but you don't spend it
it's claims on endowments private uh
funds Etc which you draw down in bad
times because then there are needs and
they're also in the private sector maybe
very real financing uh opportunities but
now you have the fund which you were
raised in Good Times it means a certain
amount of private sector involvement but
it does move you away from having to
rely on governments and trying to raise
all the money in bad times
I yes and certainly we do that you know
Ida itself issues a massive amount of
bonds on International markets 10
billion dollars so far but that number
is going up rapidly and then it can
front load in the event of a crisis as
we as as we regularly do and then also
I'll mention uh the cat DDO uh
instrument the catastrophe deferred
drawdown option that we that that we
really encourage countries to do that
means they're basically arrange a line
of credit in advance with the World Bank
uh and and then if there's an earthquake
or if there's a uh a tsunami they are
able to get um very fast disbursement we
recently did one in the Pacific Ocean in
a matter of five days after the the
crisis hit so there are various
mechanisms to do that but certainly we
could and should expand those
dramatically we're working to do
Regional instruments that diversify the
risk and as I mentioned on
infrastructure one of the big
opportunities for the world is just
recognizing that there are trillions of
dollars of uh profitable assets that are
distributed that if you could put them
into a pool there would be a way to uh
Finance it more inexpensive less
expensively but I know where Paul's
going to going to cut us off go ahead
Paul don't intend to cut you off we do
have a couple questions have come in
online while all of you are speaking the
first question comes from Carlos and he
is asking about the situation today and
how it compares to the 1980s when
inflation and debt were out of control
how is the situation better or worse
today and he follows on to ask why can't
countries and organizations learn from
the past to avoid going through the same
today
uh okay on on 80s and we could broaden
it to also in 1997 as the dollar was
strengthening currencies were getting
weaker it fell into the Asia crisis
which then spread to the whole world so
how do we avoid that uh and but uh uh uh
we we try to look at history and then uh
write reports that say let's not fall
into this again and the lesson on debt
restructuring is to do it early as early
as you can see the problem the
frustration is it's taking years to
actually get through the process that's
the point of the debt Roundtable
tomorrow
um Ragu any any comment on the 80s
versus night does this history rhyme
does it look like something in the past
I mean it it does Rhyme right we getting
into trouble in the same way as we got
into trouble with the SNL crisis so uh
you know uh boring short investing long
but we learn we learn and we don't do
the same thing it doesn't happen in
exactly the same way you know there are
reasons to be positive about the Outlook
technology has come a long way there's
much more interconnections in the world
the reason should be pessimistic uh
relative to those times so I mean I I
think it's important as you said to
learn from the past but it never is
exactly the same and and I'll add we've
never had a point in history where
interest rates were zero for a long
period of time and we also haven't had a
situation in history where central banks
who are buying bonds meaning the
duration mismatch was gigantic in the
advanced economies so both of those are
overhanging into the future so in those
two fundamental ways this is completely
different from the previous crises that
also weren't fully anticipated enough so
that that's a point for caution going
forward but also the world is richer in
total there's more Capital so we could
hope to have a faster workout from this
debt crisis Paul one more question this
one comes from Heidi and she's asking
countries that are affected by floods
droughts resulting from climate change
will have more and more difficulty
financing their needs because they're
increasingly riskier borrowers but they
will also but they will
but they will be the countries that will
need the most help how to address this
problem yeah
anyone anyone have
thought what yeah
for example in our case we had a peace
agreement to sustain our peace
and the government is very committed in
consolidating peace we need to move to
recovery and reconstruction
and we need to also address the macro
imbalance and particularly given the
multiple shocks we have undergone recent
years
the challenge is bigger but the
government commitment in terms of both
reform are very strong so getting the
right balance in terms of moving forward
is fundamentally important I think the
World Bank and IMF and other development
Partners has to has proactively support
this unique reform
in the context of the current time where
we need also additional support in terms
of financing for the construction
recovery and so for sustaining social
protection to address these multiple
challenges are fundamentally very
important I think David you should
suggest something on this one so what
we're doing in Jamaica just on that
question we are uh over the last couple
of years is putting together a suite of
financial instruments right the first
thing to recognize that as we all know
on the the quadrant of severity and
frequency uh you want to make sure you
can cover various points of that
quadrant so we have put together a menu
of financial instruments each geared to
a different point on that quadrant on
the uh lower end we are capitalizing a
natural disaster fund
um where we have taken resources and set
aside uh that can be drawn down on
certain uh triggers and we're going to
legislate what those triggers uh
ought to be and how the funds can be
used a layer above that we have
parametric Insurance that's regionally
based through an entity known as a
caravan catastrophe reinsurance
facility and then we have a layer above
that which is a credit contingent claim
where we have the financing on standby
already approved and the trigger for
drawdown would be if there is an event
and then on top of that a catastrophe
bond which uh where the Pelt is very
transparent the triggers are observable
everybody can observe and so there's no
basis risk no mismatch and when you put
those layers when we put it all together
we've assembled uh quite a good amount
of resources that can be deployed in the
event of a you know a big event now the
thing to remember is you will never be
able to ensure for the entire stock of
damage but what you want to do and what
we are trying to do is to make sure you
have enough resources to take care of
the emergency expenditure and this is
emergency expenditure the unavoidable
expenditure that can set the fiscal off
track I like to give an example in
Jamaica that in when we had our last
major very big hurricane in 1988
hurricane Gilbert it was so ferocious or
sorry it was such a direct hit that it
took a plane
at the airport and it heaved the plane
into the air
with the wings over a willow tree and if
you Google it you can see that photo
today my recollection is that well the
reason why there's a photo is that the
plane stayed there for what seemed like
weeks could have been even months
because it was not an emergency there
were emergency you have to repair the
road that connects two vital communities
you have to put the roof on the hospital
and so there are certain expenditures
that you must do and it is essential to
put financial instruments in place that
can release the expanded release
resources that can attend to those
emergency expenditures and that's what
we have done in Jamaica over the past
few years
um and something that you know we'll
continue to build on onto and to improve
yeah great great great Point
um Tina last word in uh uh on any of the
topics risk or or instruments
what I would say I I'm very pleased to
hear these kinds of ideas coming out
there have been
um soft movements in the in the sort of
academic sphere to try to roll these
kinds of ideas into standard sovereign
debt instruments and I would suggest for
everybody involved that you try to avoid
that yes because people are we're trying
to impress differently yeah they're
priced totally differently and you don't
want to intermingle those things it's
not good for the borrower and it's not
good for the lender I absolutely agree I
mean sorry if I'm I'm a borrower and
we're referring to this push to try to
put uh uh out in sovereign debt and
you're saying that not a good idea why
not do a laddering process and a
parametric Insurance process that gets
at the emergency fund yes they're
different they're different products and
you know it's like it's like in capital
markets where you get the best value not
in a conglomeration but where there's
Focus similarly uh if you you have a
financial products focused on providing
credit right and that's over here in
your financial product drugs that are
focused on risk management now you keep
them separate you get a better result
the problem with embedding is that these
are special and the the the the ability
to analyze the risk metrics don't lie in
The Sovereign credit team that's correct
so what's going to happen to countries
like us is that our sovereign debt is
going to be mispriced and usually if
it's misprice it's not going to be
missed price in my favor so
so I'm better to with especially with
the kind of reforms that we're doing
implementing physical transparency
building institutions putting laws in
place having a medium turn that
objective we're very clear on what we're
doing and we want that to be priced
properly thank you very much and then
separately we will go and price our Risk
insurance
didn't anything else that okay uh super
thanks and David any final thoughts as
we close out the session and look ahead
that this was great I want to really uh
Express appreciation to the panel
there's lots of uh the spring meetings
yet to go this week uh and these topics
are all on people's minds each each part
of this is uh under discussion and it's
critical and maybe come back to the
people in uh developing countries uh
need better prospects and all of these
techniques are part of of uh trying to
achieve that thanks everybody and thank
you to you David and thank you to our
steam panel if you'd like to watch this
back
live.wellbank.org thank you very much
[Applause]